the modern sperm whale is a magnificent
animal celebrated and feared in our
myths and literature nature reports a
major new discovery in Peru of one of
its ancestors fossilized remains an
ancestor much more fearsome that the
creature we know today
this part of the Peruvian coast about
500 kilometers south of Lima is probably
the richest place in the world for
fossil marine mammals
it's a pal intelligence paradise
christendom exam from Paris and Olivia
alarm bear from Brussels found some of
their most exciting fossils in Peru I
started working in Peru in those
localities of marine mammals and the
coast of Peru in 76 so it's about 36
years ago exactly I told all of you go
to Peru with Giovanni and start working
and they did very good job they work
very well they collected a lot of
fossils
this area the pisco iike basin it's on
the soft coast of Terry it is a desert
town area and you have very large
outcrops in which you find fossils and
so you just need to work in the desert
and look at this kind of little eels
that's always great most of the time
correspond to the presence of a facility
mammal so it's a fantastic area to study
every type of whale has its own
particular way of catching it's prey
there are two groups of cetaceans the
first one is the group of the baleen
whales like the blue in here and then
the second group is the one of the sperm
whale the group of the toothed whales
and they have such teeth baleen whales
use huge filters called plates to trap
the plankton and krill they eat they're
no threat to larger animals
but two species like the killer whales
are hunters and these were much more
numerous 12 million years ago the first
time that we arrived in Peru we
discussed with my colleague Giovanni
bianucci from the University of Pisa
what would be the great discovery that
could be done in Peru
Giovanni showed me some pictures of very
large sperm Araki's tasty weight 40
centimetres long and they were found in
Chile in the same layers as the ones in
Peru and so Giovanni just told me the
best thing that could happen to us is to
find a scale which is associated today's
and this T's and in November 2008 this
is what happens with Olivier and
Giovanni were jelly rumor from Utrecht
in the Netherlands and Mario Urbina from
Lima in Peru
Mariya found the site and klaus post
from rotterdam found the specimen itself
on the very last day of their trip we
realized that there was a huge skull of
a toothed whale the scale was partly
broken and it was upside down and what
we have seen there immediately
is huge alveoli for teeth so it means
that animal had a poor dentition so
quickly we realized that it was a new
animal new species new new genus
completely different from from what we
knew and my college of any bianucci is
proposed immediately the name revived
because this animal was related to the
sperm oil and in the famous novel of
Herman Melville mobile the sperm whale
is often called Leviathan and then we
added the species name really just in
honor of Alma Melvin's fantastic book
this is the skeleton of a modern sperm
whale the largest toothed whale or new
animal from Peru as a size similar to
this sperm whale but on this new species
there it is also on the upper jaw like
that modern sperm whale's teeth seem to
have no lower amount rather than biting
their prey usually giant squid
they suck them into their jewels
the nature paper shows a modern sperm
whale compared in size to a modern
killer whale and reveals the enormous
bite of Leviathan it had teeth on the
mandible and on the skull and the teeth
were like this you know occluding and
you had this small facet here where the
tip of the lower teeth was entering and
it's just a very facet from the lower
teeth on the upper tooth and it means
that this animal was using its teeth not
to eat squids like the recent sperm
whale but to eat big animal with
skeleton and we Olivia Nye and Giovanni
in class we think that this animal was
eating whales baleen small baleen whales
which were living in the locality in the
place in the coast of Peru by the time
20 million years ago even Herman
Melville's moby-dick would have lost any
fight with Leviathan Mel Villa from Peru
this animal was as big as a recent sperm
whale but the teeth were almost twice
bigger this tooth is about 36
centimeters long and the diameter is 12
centimeters in diameter which makes this
animal the biggest tetrapod bite ever
discovered this is unfinished business
the paleontologist will be returning to
Peru in a few months time what do they
want to learn now as it's apparent
ologist paradise and it's also a natural
laboratory of evolution because you
can't follow beds after beds did just
the fossils are just transforming you
see then the rostrum is getting longer
the teeth smaller so it's absolutely
fantastic we hope to find more for
example we don't have any idea of the
post cranial remains the virtual column
we don't know
really all wrong it was the shape of the
of the flipper we we don't know about it
so it would be interesting to find more
but also what we would like to look
after is ancestors of these pyramids
going deeper in the time and trying to
find older sperm whales but if I met one
of these animals I would be certainly
frightened because it would very easily
eat me in maybe two bites
you